[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
notre édition the dance Trophy le
concours national de danse fait étape à
plaisir du 16 au 19 octobre à la clé une
qualification pour la finale nationale à
Bordeaux nous en reparlons dans quelques
quelques instants avec notre invité du
rock du vrai c'était à les staminé pour
la 3e édition du festival food rock nous
reviendrons sur cet événement de la
scène locale les 8 et 9 novembre
l'espace de Coville à voisin accueille
deux soirées de concert autour du thème
de la Jamaïque et du Viny Nicolas Gervet
a rencontré romain franchis
l'organisateur pour toutes les
explications chaque semaine le 7è arrét
mise à l'honneur dans notre chronique
cinéphile Gael Pinot responsable du
grenier àel attrape nous lit vivre son
coup de cœur alors durant 12 mois the
dance Trophy le concours national de
danse a sillonner l'Hexagone à la
recherche des meilleurs danseurs qui
représenteront leur région pour leur
grande finale qui se tiendra à Bordeaux
en novembre après donc 13 dates de
tournée le concours fait étape à plaisir
seule date donc en Île-deFrance il a
démarrer aujourd'hui et se termine
samedi et pour en parler ce soir nous
recevons nous recevons pardon Alvaro de
soua bonsoir alors vous êtes danseur
chorégraphe et puis vous allez encadrer
les ateliers de ce concours peut-être
déjà pour préciser les choses est-ce que
vous pouvez nous nous redonner le
concept de The Dance Trophy on a
commencé ce matin déjà donc le concept
c'est un concours un concours national
donc concours amateur qui est qui est
ouvert à tous hein tout tout toute danse
toute catégories amateur ça veut dire
que ce ne sont pas des danseurs
professionnels voilà tout à fait des
écoles on on fait appel en général aux
écoles et et et autres des des des
personnes qui sont pas forcément dans un
club mais qui qui dansent depuis
longtemps ils peuvent participer il y a
aucun souci qu'est-ce qui quel type de
Danes sont représenté alors il y a
vraiment il y a vraiment toute danse
hein ça va de de la danse de couple hip
hop modern jazz danse classique c'est
vraiment tout style de danse d'accord
donc on a des danses dites de salon
c'est ça et puis la la danse
contemporaine voilà tout à fait en fait
et puis alors ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que c'est un jury prof
professionnel dont Mia Fray préside donc
ce jury donc on la connaît comme
chorégraphe célèbre chorégraphe
américaine alors je vous propose de
regarder un petit teaser donc qui va
nous donner le le ton de
[Musique]
l'événement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Alvaro à qui s'adresse exactement ce
concours on a dit donc les écoles de
danse les amateurs mais ils peuvent donc
être on a vu quelques images là en duo
ça peut être des solos ça peut être des
groupes on a eu des groupes de de 11
personnes ah oui on a eu des solos on a
vraiment on a vraiment tout tout tout
public tout âge h HM euh on a eu même un
public handicapé donc c'est vraiment
ouvert à tous alors l'événement on le
rappelle donc a lieu sur 4 jours alors 4
jours pourquoi parce qu'en fait ça se
découpe en de temps une première partie
donc ce sont 3 jours en fait
d'initiation à la danse par le BET
d'atelier et le dernier jour c'est
samedi euh bah c'est le casting c'est la
voilà c'est le le concours exactement ce
jour-là alors vous quel est votre rôle
exactement dans dans tout ça bah là
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure on a
commencé déjà ce matin donc de de 11h à
13h et de de 14h30 à 18h donc vous
animez précisément ces ateliers il y a
des ateliers danse donc euh initiation
toute danse donc eu d'accord donc on
vient vous voir avec une demande voà je
faire vous si vous voulez faire de la
salsa vous tombez bien donc il y a pas
de problème je je suis prof de de danse
latine et et également j'étais j'étais
prof pendant longtemps de danse de salon
danse sportive euh et j'ai abordé
énormément de danses donc j'ai une
approche de toutes les danses donc donc
on vient avec une demande et puis je
mets la
musique voilà donc aujourd'hui
effectivement j'ai eu un un public assez
assez divers j'ai eu des enfants j'ai
des des personnes assez âgé bon voilà
mais vraiment tout public même des
publics handicapés il y a aucun souci
euh
quel est l'objectif en fait le
l'objectif c'est vraiment partager une
le la danse avec tout le monde
c'est-à-dire c'est d'amener les gens à
venir danser avec nous partager un
moment de danse et
euh ceux qui ne dansent pas ils peuvent
ils peuvent voir parce qu'il y a des
exhibitions tout le temps donc quand il
y a pas de cours de danse on fait des
démonstrations donc ce qui fait voilà ce
qui fait que tout est gratuit et ce qui
fait que il y a tout le temps quelque
chose à voir alors on s'est rendu
justement C après-midi donc pour ce
premier jour d'atelier donc à la galerie
commerçante au champ à plaisir nous
avons rencontré d'ailleurs une des
participantes qui a dansé avec vous on
va l'écouter je me rappelle pas du nom
il fait un peu tango argentin et ça je
sais pas le faire et vous avez pris
quelque chose al oui ben qu'il faut bien
suivre son cavalier parce que c'est pas
évident hein il dans tellement bien que
faut le suivre alors voilà vous dansez
tellement bien que c'est pas facile
j'avais pas entendu c'est sympa ça fait
plaisir alors donc ce concours on l'a
dit donc a lieu dans une galerie
commerçante c'est vrai que c'est pas
très commun en fait comme comme lieu
pour un pour un concours quels sont les
les moyens qui ont qui ont été mis à
disposition bah en fait sur place on
installe un podium un grill avec des
lumières sonau comme un peu comme comme
un spectacle dans une salle sauf que là
c'est dans une galerie marchande alors
c'est vrai qu'effectivement selon la
galerie on a plus ou moins de place donc
là la plaisir c'est assez petit mais on
a eu on a eu des des des des scènes
assez assez grandes comme on peut voir
sur sur sur certaines image où où le le
grill était énorme et la la piste
également donc effectivement elle est
petite mais on arrive quand même à à
danser à se débrouiller et et puis il y
a un grand écran aussi il y a un grand
écran la Kinette donc c'est c'est un jeu
qui est parallèle et qui fait partie du
même du même projet où on où on peut on
peut jouer just Game et gagner une xbox
donc là tout ça c'est c'est gratuit tout
est gratuit on se présente ou oui c'est
100% alors donc là il y a un jeu
concours en plus pour gagner Xbox à
chaque à chaque date
on en fait on danse sur le jeu j voilà
on cumule en fait les points on note les
points et celui qui qui a le meilleur
des scores il repart avec une xbox
d'accord
alors on aurait bien aimé avoir le point
de vue d'une des participantes au
concours qui peut-être ne va pas tarder
euh comme nous sommes en direct parfois
on a quelques imprévus donc voilà l'idée
c'était de recevoir justement une
candidate qui va donc participer au
concours et puis qui va nous donner son
point de vue mais peut-être déjà pour
démarrer ce qu'on peut faire c'est
écouter les conseils de miafraay donc
qui préside le jury et qui va donc aussi
coacher les les candidats on
l'écoute c'està dire que la sélection se
fait euh par le cœur c'estàd c'est à
partir du moment où on s'aperçoit que
quelqu'un ou un groupe est vraiment dans
son sujet dans une vraie sincérité de ce
qu'il ce qu'il a envie de raconter je
pense que forcément c'est cela qui qui
me donne envie de les choisir il y a
évidemment la mise en scène il y a le
thème choisi il y a costume il y a la
scénographie difficulté de la
chorégraphie on a C critères bah surtout
d'être dans une sincérité et dans une
énergie c'estàd que même quand c'est des
choses plus suave que ce soit la danse
contemporaine ou que ça soit la danse
classique ou il faut absolument vraiment
dégager un truc très précis très clair
et surtout la synchronisation parce que
ça aussi c'est un problème et ça aussi
ça fait partir de ça fait partie de no
critère c'est c'est c'est c'est la
synchro c'estd qu'à partir du moment où
vous êtes deux il faut être ensemble
souvent l'ouverture ou la
fermeture d'une chorégraphie parfois bah
c'est pas abouti c'estàd que les gens
bon soit au début ils ont une pause ils
ont c'est clair mais la fin c'est un peu
voilà ouf j'ai fini donc non c'estd que
jusqu'au bout il faut que tout
soit précis propre et et
clair alors nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau Anne bonsoir donc vous êtes
danseuse pour l'association unitime donc
vous allez participer au concours alors
déjà j'ai envie de vous demander
qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à participer
à ce concours pourquoi the dance Trophy
bah déjà tout d'abord l'année dernière
on a participé à l'ancien dance Trophy
donc dence Oscar donc là c'est la deuxè
édition deours voà donc l'année dernière
on est resté sur un résultat plus ou
moins correct donc on est arrivé 5e on
voulait retenter cette année pour
essayer d'aller beaucoup plus loin et
beaucoup plus hautou un top 3 et on va
essayer on espère ouais et aussi faire
participer nos autres nos trois autres
groupes en fait VO vous êtes vous êtes
quatre groupe à particip à concours et
vous votre groupe précisément vous allez
présenter quoi quel type de chorégraphie
alors on va donc déjà nous notre style
c'est plus du style
afrocibéen nous on va présenter ce qu'on
appelle enfin ce qu'on a appelé nous
dance enfin c'est plus de la house
mélange avec de la dan sou voilà c'est
un petit concept à nous on dévoile pas
tout bien sûr alors quelle préparation
vous avez dû mettre en œuvre pour pour
ce concours ou est-ce que ça fait
quelque chose que vous travaillez déjà
depuis plusieurs mois bah en fait on
avait déjà nos principales idées après
c'est vrai qu'on l'a su en mai juin je
crois donc après c'est vrai que quelques
filles sont partis en vacances d'autres
travaillaient donc on s'y est vraiment
mis début septembre en fait on avait
déjà les musiques qu'on voulait mettre
les thèmes les costumes et tout donc
c'est vrai que c'est allé plutôt vite
d'accord donc ça ça fait quoi un un mois
finalement que vous travaillez
sérieusement votre chégraphie vous allez
être combien bah al nous dans notre
groupe on est 6 et dans les trois autres
groupes donc il y a un groupe de qu un
groupe de 7 et un groupe de 6 encore
d'accord donc vous avez entendu les
conseils de
miafy donc il faut une cohérence dans la
chorégraphie du début jusqu'à la fin
pensez bien l'ouverture la
fermeture la synchronisation vous Alvaro
qu'est-ce qui est selon vous qu'est-ce
qui
le partage le partage c'est très
important le regard qu'on danse pas seul
on est on est allez être avec le public
il faut partager donc il faut faut les
regarder il faut regarder les juris il
faut être à l'aise en fait il faut
éviter de regarder le
sol ça c'est c'est très très important
et puis voir quand on voit que les
danseurs prennent du plaisir sont
motivés ça ça nous fait à nous quelque
chose et nous on est danseur donc on
sait ce que c'est euh le travail
derrière on on le voit tout de suite
donc après après les petites différences
ce qui va faire la différence c'est ça
c'est c'est qu'on sente que vous êtes à
l'aise ça c'est important en tout cas
merci à tous les deux d'être venus sur
le plateau du C donc pour nous parler de
ce grand concours The Dance Trophy donc
qui démarre aujourd'hui 3 jours
d'initiation à la danse et le casting
c'est samedi donc à la galerie
commerçante pardon de plaisir on vous
souhaite le meilleur merci merci à vous
et puis merci encore une fois à tous les
deux donc nous poursuivons avec un
festival pas comme les autres puisqu'il
s'est tenu vendredi et samedi pour sa
3ème édition c'est le festival food rock
à Manille et à mot de jours de rock mais
du vrai retour sur cet événement en
image avec pardon imag pardon de Julien
Leroi amateur de rock dérive de guitares
électriques au son saturé c'est à les
staminé à Manil et Amou que se sont
retrouvés ces 400 passionnés au festival
food rock alors ob de ce festival c'est
promouvoir le rock dans tous ces états
donc ce qui nous ce qui nous guide c'est
c'est on va dire le taux de distorsion
entre les groupes donc on va du blouses
au métal donc l'ambition c'est ça et ce
qu'on fait on associe des têtes
d'affiche nationales et des petits
groupes de la région qu'on veut
promouvoir alors c'est de la région et
d'un peu plus loin dans certains cas
c'est c'est beaucoup de coup de cœur
festival de proximité cette 3e édition
prend toutefois une nouvelle dimension
plus internationale avec des AR venu
tout droit
[Musique]
d'outreatlantique pour le cas Dolls qui
est en train d'exploser aux US qui en
train d'exploser en Europe il n'arriv
pas rentrer en France parce qu'il avent
pas de contact il y a pas de y a pas de
chose forcément établ et on est rentr
rentré en contact directement avec eux
aux États-Unis quand ils ont ils ont su
qu'ils pouvait avoir la possibilité de
venir un festival proche de Paris on est
à 20 minutes de Paris et ben les gars
ils étaient très enthousiastes la PR qui
correspond à mes bot musicaux et
soutenir une initiative de ce genre
parce que c'est pas c'est pas souvent
qu'on a ce genre de concert dans la
région ou même en France en général donc
c'est toujours sympa d'en profiter quand
ça se
présente
on a des des genres musicaux qui sont
assez variés et des groupes qui sont
sympas donc il y a une bonne ambiance
c'était très bon en fait il y avait
vraiment pour tous les goûts des
découvertes et puis deux groupes qui
m'ont motivé particulièrement à venir
Bukovski et the yen du côté des artistes
comme the yen les anciens musicien du
groupe Noir Désir ou encore seven weeks
le festival est surtout une occasion de
jouer sur scène nous on est flatté déjà
qu'on nous sollicite pour venir jouer
donc ça veut dire que voilà que ce soit
dans un petit festival dans un grand
dans un moyen dans un petit club voilà
l'idée c'est l'idée de d'être musicien
c'est d'aller jouer et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
nous ce qui nous plaît c'est de de
vraiment vraiment vivre les morceaux et
donc de faire des choses ambiant et en
jouant sur les contrastes à côté de
choses qui sont assez
péchu ça c'est ce qui nous plaît et
c'est ce qu'on s'amuse vraiment à faire
sur
[Musique]
scène
la programmation 2013 sur 2 jours
confirme l'ambition du festival devenir
un événement majeur dans la
[Musique]
régionci retrouvons tout de suite
Nicolas Gervet pour sa chronique dans le
kiosque semaine Nicolas nous fait
découvrir le Jamaican plate organisé
donc par l'association metasos toutes
les explications on écoute Jamaican
plate qu'est-ce que c'est c'est le
nouveau concept concocté par metasso
pour tous les amateurs de réget et leurs
amis et c'est les 8 et 9 novembre à la
salle de la tour à voisin encore une
soirée ù tu vas finir en LOX en LOX tu
as
compris
[Musique]
ate donc c'est une c'est un nouveau
concept qu'on a voulu développer pour
cette saison donc c'est un concept qui
tourne autour donc des musiques R et Deb
qui sont
des de styles Music qui ont pris leur
racine donc dans sur les terres
jamaïcaines dans les années 60 la
différence entre ces deux styles c'est
que le réget donc c'est tout ce qui est
musique avec des voix et le dub c'est
justement cette même musique reprise
mixée mais sans les
[Musique]
voix
c'est deux phases d'un même disque donc
la phase A qui va commencer donc le
vendredi soir par le rég et la phase B
avec le deb le
[Musique]
samedi personne n' de
l'histoire
évapor personnellement
j'aié
[Musique]
êtes-vous déjà allé en haut du
mon alle de vendredi 8 novembre nous
avons en tête d'affiche the Aquatics
Elman and friends et so qui est un
groupe de nos studios avec Z Aquatics on
est plus sur du Rocking
regmanu and friends c'est plus du reg
roots sol Diaz qui est notre groupe des
studios explore tous les styles du réga
mais qui plus tourner vers le Dan et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'UR
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le samedi 9 novembre nous avons en tête
d'affiche de Burman e dupler et ancorome
deberman qui fait un dub plus
électronique avec des teintes de rock
après on a
niikrom qui est plus beaucoup plus sur
du dub rock ou dub Méal avec une
ambiance
psychédéliqueler qui fait du
dub expérimental qui s'exprime par des
diffusions au cours du set
[Musique]
vidéo pour assister au de soirs c'est 9
€ et pour les chaque soir séparé c'est 6
[Musique]
€ et voilà le Jamaican P donc c'est les
8 et 9 novembre à la salle de la tour à
voisin
yes compris Aela c'est à vous faut lui
expliquer c'est à VOUS Aelia B c'est ça
Nico positive vibration et à la semaine
prochaine passons tout de suite à notre
chronique
cinéphile nous sommes mercredi c'est
donc l'heure des sorties cinées au micro
d'élo di moine bien je trouve ça pas mal
amusant sans plus extraordinaire du
Pontel c'est vraiment un génie dans le
domaine de de l'humour la poésie tout
tout est bon dans ce film rien acheté
extraordinaire il va faire un carton
c'est sûr c'est évident le bouche à
oreille de dru va marcher ça c'est
extraordinaire je suis un peu restée sur
ma fa voilà c'estàdire que je crois
qu'il y a le battage médiatique été
tellement important que je m'attendais
un petit peu à mieux mais bon c'est tout
mais sinon c'est un bon film il y a de
bons gag ou c'est très très très bien
pour les enfants très rigolo il a de
l'humour ou c'est très sympa c'était
marrant et
c'était cétait trop bien j'ai trouvé ce
film très sympathique et puis les
enfants vont voir les escargots
différemment maintenant j'ai trouvé que
c'était un film un petit dessin animé
pour les enfants qui étaient très bien
le graphisme était beau aussi et je
pense que la petite elle a bien aimé
c'est c'est super bien fait les les
dessins sont bien faits et vraiment
c'est très sympa pour les enfants donc
voilà non non il y a que du bien voilà
ça ressemble un petit peu à cars et
c'est très bien oui c'est sympa c'est
j'étais un petit peu déçu parce que
c'est pas complètement l'univers de
Jeunet mais bon c'est pas
mal la chronique cinéphil c'est aussi
l'occasion d'entendre un professionnel
nous donner son coup de cœur cette
semaine c'est au tour de Gael Pino
responsable du cinéma Le Grenier à Sel
attrape cette semaine au grenier à cel
je voudrais vous proposer le film elle
s'en va c'est un road movie réalisé par
Emmanuel Berco un l'histoire du film
c'est Betti une femme qui a passé la
soixantaine tout sécroule autour d'elle
son amant s'en va son son restaurant se
casse la figure
elle en a marre elle claque la porte
elle prend la voiture elle va faire un
tour de pâté de maison et puis ce petit
tour se transforme en
échappé et tout est prétexte pour ne pas
rentrer je reviens et ça dure comme ça
donc c'est un film de rencontre un film
de réconciliation aussi avec sa fille
c'est l'actrice principale c'est donc
Catherine deu et la risatrice manuel
Berco dit ce film a été
pour et ça a été le moteur du film on
trouve aussi enre autre acteur on
retrouve Camille la chanteuse Camille
qui jou fille de Catherine de neuv on
retrouve aussi
av on retrouve milen de Monot et Paul
ami qui est le qui on retrouve bientôt
dans un film avec Sarah foresier qui
s'appelle Suzanne qu'on retrouvera sur
nos écrans dans quelques mois la
réalisatrice donc Emmanuel Berco on
connait peu son nom et pourtant elle a
fait beaucoup en tant que réalisatrice
et en tant
et notamment en tant qu'actrice on l'a
vu dans Carlos de oliva sayas on l'a vu
dans Les petits mouchoirs on l'a vu dans
police qu'elle a coécrit avec mywen
et et donc ce ce film là elle s'en va et
c'est un de ses premiers longmétrages on
en a fait deux ou trois il me semble
donc c'est un film auquel on tient
beaucoup au Gren qu'on vous invite à
venir voir et pour retrouver les horair
vous pouvez regarder sur
www.cinemagrenacel.com
pour vos sorties culturelles je vous
propose trois dates aujourd'hui alors
vendredi une sortie de théâtre une
journée ordinaire donc une pièce avec
Alain Delon et sa fille Anouchka qui
entame donc une tournée à travers la
France ce sera donc vendredi à 20h30 à
la Ferme du Manet à Montini si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez également assister
à une soirée salsa un concert précédé de
cours cour d'initiation et des
dégustations de tapasse et proposé à
l'estaminé à maniléamo et c'est aussi
vendredi à 20h30 vous pouvez également
si vous le souhaitez donc tout est
questions de choix assister au concert
de sherifa c'est une chanteuse et
poétesse du Moyen Atlace qui évoque les
couleurs orientales et les teintes
africaines en chant et en musique c'est
également vendredi ce sera là à la
merurise à trappe notre édition est à
présent terminée je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivi sur T F je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine à 18h30 en
direct à
[Musique]
bientôt